Like I said in the question video, there
are many, many different values for a and
b that you could enter here. But perhaps,
the simplest way is to let a= -17, and to
let b=1.
This is an easy way to express any
integer. We can write 3 as 3/1 and 29 as
29/1 and -300 as -300/1. But we could also
come up with many other fractions that
reduce to these integers if we multiply
the numerator and the denominator, or a
and b, each by the same number. In the
case of -17, for example, if we multiply
the top and bottom by 2, then we get
-34/2, which is another acceptable answer
to this quiz. Or you could have put 51/-3
or 17/-1. If you're feeling at all shaky
on fractions right now, please take some
time to do some of the practice problems
we've provided on fractions or watch some
of the supplemental material we've linked
to.